last of the mini courses for this
bootcamp and so she'll give the first
part today in the last two parts
tomorrow and we'll also in the morning
have a talk from Deirdre Mulligan if she
makes it I actually got an email from
her saying some complications up her
it'll be good so Katrina is also one of
the organizers and she's going to be
talking about a bunch of different
things many of which are related to kind
of one of the reading groups we'd like
to run this semester so I this first
portion of the talk for today is
reasonably separate from the two
portions tomorrow today I'll be talking
about this data co-ops idea which is
with kopi and then tomorrow I'll be
doing a sort of more general talk on
various themes from economics in game
theory that relate to the study of
privacy and there there will be plenty
of connections and in particular I all
sort of extract out all of the game
theory and economics questions that
should have been in today's talk and
save them for tomorrow for you there
wouldn't have been time anyway okay so
they this is really a collection of
preliminary thoughts as Adam alluded to
Kobe and I are planning on writing a
working group around this theme over the
course of the semester so hopefully this
is the beginning of a conversation with
many of you and the source of a lot of
questions and ideas so the starting
point for this discussion is this world
that we live in one in which personal
data are so incredibly central to
advertising and to sales strategic
decision making that the company is they
are managing to access our data to
collect it store it make sense of it
have turned it into the world's most
valuable resource
so a 20-17 economist article and there
have been other quotes that I've seen
that have alluded to this has argued
that data has replaced oil as the
world's most valuable resource this is
the world we live in and given that it's
not so surprising that this amazing rich
landscape has arisen around monetizing
data there's been a lot of creative
innovation in this space people are
doing really amazing things and solving
really really interesting problems using
personal data there's a lot of fun stuff
going on there one thing that we've
noticed in recent years is that there's
also a lot of concern in this space and
there have been a number of efforts and
I'll show you a few of them trying to
respond to various concerns around uses
of personal data I said some of them are
for profits like this startup that I try
to help you get back some control of
your personal data perhaps in exchange
for something in this particular case
this is there's an opportunity for users
to exchange their data for special
offers from brands there here's another
example and a non-profit cooperative
that focuses on health data sort of it
forming a data repository so people can
donate their data to a project like this
make it more accessible to researchers
another effort we've seen this is an
effort to started as an academic one and
has now become a nonprofit organization
sort of an ecosystem of small
organizations focused on this idea of
letting people take their data out of
sort of the central repositories and
move them to what they calm sort of
micro servers providing high security
and some increased degree of control
over your personal data other efforts
sort of with similar themes coming up in
lots of places here's another one again
I with this idea that maybe data
shouldn't be tied to the application
maybe Dana shouldn't be held or sort of
I managed by the companies that are
using our data perhaps we should be
returning data to people and then there
are sort of more less technical more
sort of political responses to the
current landscape the data union it's a
nonprofit with an with a vision of sort
of giving people some sort of collective
voice to negotiate with the big names
who are using our data so lots of
efforts in the space responding to lots
of different concerns so that you try to
identify some of the concerns that these
projects have been responding to and
what is this sort of overarching feeling
that the internet that we have is not
the internet that we were promised I
that somehow the internet started out is
this this venue for giving control to
the people and there was this sense of
excitement and empowerment and
individual eye control and that somehow
now we've we live in this world with a
handful of dominant platforms and many
people view this is problematic for a
number of reasons and one of them is
that a handful of platforms is a few
potential massive points of failure and
that's failure in lots of different
senses failure and sort of the obvious
senses of security vulnerabilities and
hacks but also failure in terms of
incentives if I mean if one of these
companies has incentives to do something
that we're not so happy with it's a
society that can have a huge impact on
society
so we're there there are a lot of
concerns about the interface internet
that we that we have today and some of
the the startups that I mentioned and
efforts in this space focus on missed
opportunities for innovation in today's
ecosystem so what I mean by this well
you know I said there's so much
data out there so much being collected
it's so exciting there's so much you can
do with it but actually it's not so
clear if you are a researcher or a small
startup you can really get your hands on
the data that you need in this current
ecosystem so say you're a small start-up
and you're interested in linking to
different types of data that don't
generally show up in the same database
you want to understand purchasing habits
and mental health information those
together because you have a really great
idea that's gonna help people say you
want to get at some really really
specific sub population you have a great
product that's gonna help people who are
in a very particular situation if a
creative idea how do you reach those
people in today's ecosystem you're if
you're not one of the big players in the
space say you want to deliver highly
tailored experience to your users that
might depend on a lot of personal
information but you don't want to get in
the business of actually having and
gathering all of that personal
information how do you go about that
in today's ecosystem so actually there
are a lot of challenges particularly if
you're not one of the big players but
even if you're one of the big players in
getting access to the data that you
might want there's also this question
that maybe that the acts the access
isn't just the only problem maybe the
data that you want isn't being collected
in the first place because there are a
lot of barriers to the collection of
high quality production and collection
and production of high-quality data so
we saw a lot of these themes already in
focus talk but you know sometimes
there's no existing market for the data
so why would anybody begin be gathering
it we live in a world where quality data
isn't really compensated so why would
high quality data be can be gathered and
of course there's so many risks to
holding data the many companies and many
researchers are very very nervous about
doing it you open yourself up to
breaches to subpoenas
to GDP are violations so actually this
rich and amazing landscape is not
necessarily a landscape that gets the
best data into the right hands and of
course we saw a lot of those efforts
that I mentioned earlier on responding
to individuals concerns about the
current data landscape issues like I
don't actually really know who gets
access to my data and for what purpose
I don't know what I'm trading for what I
mean I have this sense that I go online
and I'm trading my data for something
but I don't really have a very good
sense of what that trade-off is and the
potential consequences of that trade-off
are far from transparent to me as a user
and sometimes you just start to get the
sense that everybody is making money off
of your data for you so a lot of people
are unhappy with the status quo and
trying to figure out things to do about
this and it's an illustration of what
passes for individual control and
autonomy in the in the current landscape
is this fantastic website provided by
AXA comm one of the big data brokers
they offer you to you know this
opportunity to demystify the data sphere
and return control to your hands which
is basically an opportunity for you to
go in and correct the information they
have about you so they know more about
you and way we live in this world where
a you know reading the privacy policies
you encounter in a year would take you
seventy six work days and of course this
is from some number of years ago so
forgot it you're gonna take all year at
this so what can we do so as I mentioned
there are a lot of ideas out there and
more every day so Coby and I take it get
together some students gathered
something like 30 different I startups
and academic efforts that are in this
space and I'm every day I hear about
four of them and they tend to fall
around a number of themes there are a
bunch of efforts around the theme of
trying to help people monetize their
personal data try to rectify this sense
that everybody else is making money and
hey shouldn't I get
piece of that there are a lot of efforts
trying to make more and better data
available for research there are a
number of efforts that are around themes
of restoring individual control and
trying to get data sort of back into
individuals hands in various ways I
mentioned a couple of these already one
that stands out in this list sort of
because it's a little bit of a slightly
different flavor and an interesting
story is this data as labor movement
there's there's been work sort of at
both academic and outside of the
academic community advocating for the
protection and recognition of data
actually as a form of labor and if you
think of data as work it has all sorts
of consequences legal and otherwise and
some of them align very in very
interesting ways with some of these
other concerns that I talked about so
this whole set of concerns and efforts
it's me looks like an opportunity so
there's a real opportunity here to sit
back a bit and think about how can I
formalize the problem and how can we
organize the concerns and what can be
done in this space and so that's a lot
of what I'm trying to do with this talk
so Coby and I together have identified
what we view is sort of three essential
pillars of any solution to take on these
myriad problems in this data landscape
and so one of the things we'll do is
talk about those a bit more today but
the three for us are creation of value
so what do I mean by that whatever the
solution is it's gonna have to take
people's personal data and to transform
it into something that has more value
than we were getting as a society before
we have to think about meaningful
individual control so whatever solution
this is going to be has to be giving
real people choices that they can
actually make and handle that that give
them sort of the opportunity to
understand what's going on with their
data and
to make some choices about it and we
have to think in a really really serious
way about security and privacy and so
those are sort of for us the three
things that are going to be essential to
any solution here we talked a little bit
about what what each of those means and
so what am I trying to do here this is a
very strange talk right I didn't come
here to tell you about work that's
already been done I didn't really come
here to take you view a survey about
anything so and so what I'm really
trying to do here is to start a
discussion as I mentioned before so when
I think about we're going somewhere we
are somewhere as a society what are the
alternative paths forward let's reckon
with where we're going right now and
think about whether or not that's what
we want and what are the other
possibilities and then what we really
have to do is to build a research
community broadly around what we're
gonna call this data co-op idea which
I'll get to in a minute
and understand the research challenges
in building a solution in this space and
what we'd like to do is really come up
with any of you who are interested with
lots of ideas and tools that could
potentially serve lots of different
initiatives that share some of the goals
that I've described so far so as part of
us we really need to understand what
what should the principles and ground
rules of work in this space be what are
the goals for group work in this space
and I want to emphasize throughout that
we're not looking to commit to a single
model to a single solution we don't want
this semester build the answer and you
know convert society over to another
model we want to explore the space and
we want to build those tools that let
people explore in this space so I want
to talk a bit more about what Coby and I
have identified as sort of the key
pillars of a solution and what that
might look like and try to make this a
little bit more concrete for us all to
have something to talk about and then to
think about sort of would it be the
implications of really changing the
model by which we hold and transact on
data and then to talk a little bit but
this is where you all hopefully come in
about the research agendas that are
raised
by completely rethinking of how we
transact and hold on data so so how many
coop provide value of control and
security so what do I mean when I say a
data call so here's one vision of what a
data co-op could look like so the idea
is instead of the current model where
companies come along and collect your
data sort of as part of your interaction
with them and then do who knows what
with it I individuals could opt to join
a data cooperative and they could opt to
funnel some or all of their personal
data through the coop and the coop would
act on their behalf in any negotiation
involving someone some entity who would
like to use their data and so all of
these companies that are interested in
using my data here they need to
negotiate with my coop in order to do so
potentially they compensate the coop for
access to various data products that the
coop provides some of that compensation
potentially flows back to me as an
individual but the idea is that I as an
individual can express my preferences to
the coop in some way and then I can
entrust the coop to act on my behalf so
this makes it a little bit more concrete
and so then it's sort of against this
context we can talk again about those
three pillars so what could it co-op do
here so a co-op could create value for
society in a number of ways so the coop
immediately can create data products
that just you can't dream up in today's
ecosystem because the coop potentially
is bringing together huge amounts of
data of different types that currently
would never dream of lying in the same
database it's potentially bringing
together data that you know currently
isn't even gathered much higher quality
data isn't currently being gathered and
it has the ability to market all sorts
of sophisticated data products and this
is all being done with people's consent
meaningfully expressed and permission
and so you get yourself out of a lot of
trouble that you might otherwise be in
trying to create these interesting data
products
the perspective of somebody who wants to
use data the co-op's also providing
value because the COPE could potentially
in addition to providing these amazing
new data products be actually providing
data science tools so maybe you don't
want to have an in-house privacy expert
an in-house data science expert and
in-house you know group of statisticians
you don't want to have to think about
privacy regulations and various
jurisdictions the coop can take care of
all of that you say this is what I need
from this population the coop can
provide it could potentially really by
centralizing some aspects that this
market eliminate a number of existing
sort of frictions and inefficiencies the
second pillar that we mentioned was
control so how can the coop enable
personal control of data so one thing
that is really important here is that we
envision most people not really wanting
to think about the nitty-gritty of where
their data is going and for what purpose
son you know at this very moment and
exactly which sources are being combined
and exactly what compensation they're
getting most people want to fix it and
forget it solution when it comes to
thinking about their personal data and
the coop could potentially provide that
by providing delegated decision-making
you come to the coop and you adopt a
data preferences profile maybe one of a
handful recommended by various outside
experts you click this is how I want my
data to be handled and then the coop
takes care of it for you and so that
delegated decision-making where the coop
can act on your behalf
potentially really gives you a lot more
control than systems where you are
expected to be the one to read and to
click into the sides the goal would be
to provide of course individuals with a
variety of meaningful understandable
choices I realize that those are very
difficult things to achieve to control
how data are being used and by whom for
what purpose the coop should allow
people to change their choices to revoke
them to revise them to update them and
the coop should continually provide to
individuals an update of how their data
are being used
and the risks that they might be taking
on hope is really providing you with an
amazing amount of control and
transparency potentially then the third
thing pillar that we had there was
security and privacy so really not
surprisingly given the context of this
particular discussion of privacy is near
and dear to our hearts and it's
absolutely essential that as part of
this you're giving individuals access to
meaningful trade-offs between data use
and risks and the benefits and and so
it's really important that as much as
possible we think concretely and
rigorously about the risks of data users
that we measure them that we track them
that we help people understand them that
we help people control them and
absolutely one of the advantages of the
cop is that collectively it could help
people advocate for better privacy
protections for better security
protections and the coop could actually
be an active eye protector of members in
the sense of vigilantly auditing for
unauthorized uses of data advocating for
members rights potentially even in
political arenas and pursuing legal
action
so the coop can be a combination of
solutions not just a legal solution not
just a technical solution but a hybrid
sort of all the tools that we have at
our disposal to help protect people and
advocate for their rights so if you guys
are sort of a the things that are really
essential to helping us build a tool
that can address the concerns in this
data space I want to try to make it even
a little bit more concrete by going
through a couple of questions that might
be in the back of your mind right now so
talking about this coop thing what what
are the types of data that could
potentially be held by a co-op and the
answer is kind of a non-answer in the
sense that it could be anything and
everything that's currently being
gathered about you and many things that
you haven't even dreamed it could be
gathered about you the idea though would
be that you as an individual would can
contain would can
have control and choice in this space
Culp's could potentially choose to focus
some of them on particular data domains
you might see medical data coops emerge
as a specific area maybe you see coops
really making benef getting benefit from
the idea of really bringing together
very disparate types of data but you
should think of this as potentially a
very very broad collection of types of
data another natural question is okay so
this model is really foreign and very
different from how we currently work
with data how does this fit with the
existing wobble what would happen to the
companies already have about me and the
immediate answer is again sort of a
non-answer in the sense that well
nothing would immediately happen to the
data that's already held by you that's
that's out there I can't change that and
companies that could continue to operate
in their current model alongside an
emerging coop model now it is possible
that if the coop model were to gain
traction that might put pressure on
organizations that have sort of the
traditional models of data collection
and usage to change some of their
practices but this is something that
could potentially really coexist with
the existing model so similarly what
would happen to your current free
services where you're exchanging data
for something yeahthere's well that
could continue to exist alongside
services that would evolve to negotiate
directly with the coop and be a little
bit more transparent about the
trade-offs that they're offering and I
imagine that if coops were successful
that the trade-offs the companies would
offer would change with time and then I
think the other big thing that I imagine
might be in your mind at this point is
who's buying what from the coop what is
it exactly that the coop is gonna sell
is this coop gonna sell my browsing
history to a tow company are they gonna
sell my medical records to a company and
the answer is I guess they could but
probably not
cuz that's probably not what these
companies really need what they really
need mostly are things like aggregate
statistics trends correlations ability
to target but they don't actually
necessarily really need access to your
data in order to target the answer is
though it's open for discussion
and this is one of the interesting
questions is what are the kinds of
things that are called white market and
how should you price things like that
okay so hopefully this gives you some
sense of of what we're we're proposing
in this to sort of explore in this place
yeah why would you want to give your
data to a cop so as it from the
individuals perspective
hopefully the coop would offer you a
number of protections that you couldn't
achieve as an individual going over it
alone I don't really have the ability to
go around to all the companies who
currently interact with and say hey I'm
gonna stop interacting with you unless
you give me better privacy protections
we're gonna say good luck to you if you
work with a group of people to negotiate
for better security for better privacy
for more transparency you have a hope of
negotiating you also when you join a
group of people you increase the value
of your data and formally we can talk
about the value of data is more than the
sum of its parts so when you come
together with other people you actually
can get a financial benefit in addition
to this negotiating power so the help
would they would be that you would be
getting lots of benefits in exchange
there's a concern of course how do you
get something like this started because
initially there probably wouldn't be
such great benefits speaking of getting
this done it would you mind going back
to the side with the different
like Miko sure sure yeah so I've been
following the birth of these a little
bit great but I have never looked in
detail on sort of their model but I was
wondering in your the full survey of
them in when you will be developed
what does the data cook do that these
models don't write and so it's a weird
to get because of different angles are
covered by many things yeah yeah yeah so
one thing is that I have yet to see
another effort that gets privacy right
that's sort of a universal many of these
efforts are missing the sort of
collective aspect where you create value
by bringing together many people's data
and the collective aspect where you
create an organization that can go she
ate so there's a lot of a lot of the
efforts that are in the right direction
on security or privacy are also very
distributed and individualistic and
they're missing this collective action
aspect of things I mean some of these
are for-profit efforts with very dubious
benefits to the individuals and very
dubious business models in some cases so
it's I have yet to see all of these in
place but it may be that I've missed
something and I would actually love to
see somebody saying well here are three
efforts that actually have more
commonalities and you've realised with
data coops because that would allow us
to think about tools that could serve
all of these efforts at once and
actually I'll talk about this more later
but I I think it would be great to see
diversity in the space of ideas and in
implementations and so if you've done
some survey in this space I'd love to
hear about you know what you're aware of
and the efforts that we should know
about other questions at this point yeah
I mean yes yes yeah so I was alluding to
to him when I when I talked about data
is labor and yeah I've talked with him
and Rachel's talked too closely with him
about related ideas in the space and
what we're advocating for is very very
well aligned in many regards we have
slightly different priorities and
perspectives and motivations but it was
very rewarding to to realize that coming
with those different perspectives and
motivations we've come to very similar
perspectives on the problem in many ways
yeah yes so there there's this book of
been while and Eric Posner called
radical markets one of the chapters in
this book is on data as labor
specifically each of the chapters sort
of do you know proposes a radical idea
for sort of changing how we do something
I can hold back in the world and this is
one of the chapters they're not stick
will be said you shouldn't track us
we'll track ourselves and then we'll do
some processing blah blah blah
well like coming in as an interview
right so so this idea of getting larger
and negotiating poops really makes sense
but then you had a question what is the
principle according to which you create
what you present it so far
it can take some of the constraints some
of them are actually incompatible with
one another and it may be what you're
saying which is great maybe they're not
unions if they're not unions and you
become fermented and I think this is
politically wise ideas that you know the
coop says look at what we're doing and
then if you join us you're subscribed
under though so when you talk about
individual control it's not like you go
to the coop as an agent and say this is
what I want make sure you get it
so the different models and by the way
the idea being targeted but not revealed
data that's what simply after is so it
might still run afoul of certain kinds
of privacy constraints so I I mean I'm
not digging the principal office
intermediary that carries certain of the
principles that the theory of privacy
might work I'm just
but when you lay out the constraints you
might then need to create rather
radically great yeah so that's a good
points in there let me just draw in a
couple of them but I think we'll need to
return to them over the course of days
and weeks and years so so one of them
potential tensions between the sort of
pillars of the solution there's
something I'd love to continue the
conversation about I think I think that
there's something requires more more
detail but it mean if particular
tensions that come to mind please note
them and we'll continue the conversation
on that on the idea that I the
individual controls might be something
you have to see it I actually disagree
with you a lot I think that the the coop
well it's certainly true that a co-op
will need to make decisions on behalf of
the group they just the couple need to
for example prioritize how to spend the
revenue it gets from from selling data
products and so this is not something
where you are necessarily gonna get what
you want and I'm gonna get what I want
if what I want is to spend the revenue
on advocacy and you want to spend the
revenue on putting that money in your
pocket so we may not both get what we
want and there will need to be some form
of governance and there will need to be
some form of decision-making and there
may need to be multiple coops that have
different guiding principles and you may
subscribe to one and I may subscribe to
another but I think within each co-op
there should be the ability for
different individuals to have different
priorities in the census I might decide
that I'm not just I'm not gonna let
anybody touch my medical data and you
might decide that you want all of your
medical data to go directly into the
hands of any researcher who requests it
and the co-ops ought to have some
ability for us to express these very
different preferences about data usage
lots of really good things in your point
I think we have to hold the rest of them
and continue on but thank you keep
noting them down and I want to come back
to them all
we're not advocating for specific
setting a specific solution we are
observing that things happen now in the
world and we believe bringing our
technical understanding our ability to
abstract generalize formalize these
problems in the very crucial in making
tools for these projects to do things
right so it may be in the country an
already mentioned that we're not
advocating like one core solution and I
think you to the recent agenda and it's
like many very interesting questions
that are many of which ok so let me skip
ahead a bit back where we were
and so we talked about the concrete
questions let's talk briefly about sort
of what the this future might look like
and then I want to get into the research
agendas a bit so so a number of things
might change in a future with some
version of data coops we might see some
existing things that get done with data
done in slightly different ways with
very different guarantees to individuals
we might see totally new applications
emerged to take advantage of new
opportunities in data and we'd see sort
of a new player this co-op emerge in the
data arena and there are some
implications to that so I think it's
worth doing a little bit of thinking
about sort of what might change about
existing applications existing uses of
personal data and sort of the thing to
keep in mind is that changes might
actually be fairly gradual I coop of
some sort might actually provide
primarily provide legal protections and
advocacy and awareness rather than
technical solutions is this something
that might change with time
as the coop matures the the set of
technical tools available but it in
issue it might be let's all agree that
we're only going to you know give our
data to such-and-such a company if they
agree to give us a more reasonable more
understandable contract that could be an
initial action of a co-op yes you look
disturbed by this I don't want to be
skipped because I think it's a great
idea but the moment you said data is
labor it just struck me like this we are
very much in a situation where we don't
have control of our theta much like
people did not have control of the
fruits of their labor
back when the industrialization started
but what was the solution the solution
was strike and it just doesn't strike
the strike is being feasible right now
right kids like this thing if you were
to design me a computer like this then I
would trust you for all the security
reasons but I'm not going to trust you
that it's gonna work so I I think I say
what you mean about a strike I mean
there are those who actually advocate
that that's the way forward I share some
of your skepticism about that yeah let's
let's hold the discussion of launch
strategies but I think that is one of
the critical research questions that
needs to be explored is how could you
get something like this off the ground
and hat because hopefully I can convince
you that sort of at equilibrium
something like this could work I think
the really tricky thing is how do you
get there
so let's return to that theme time
permitting
over the courses semester let's return
to that thing you have to think a little
bit in order to think about existing
applications and what might change in
this new world
what a value is currently being
exchanged who's giving what to whom and
what the opportunities of changing the
model is that you can unshackle yourself
from this idea that you have to pay with
data that's the only currency that you
have in most of these interactions a
useful question is to think about for
applications does personal data actually
need to be transmitted in order to
achieve the goals of whatever this
application is so for example for
thinking about email how much that
change in a data co-op world
well maybe the coop would help provide
you know sort of incentives and for
structure encouragement in directions of
security encryption maybe there would be
ideas a mixing networks maybe you could
give strong or guarantees for data that
stays within the co-op so if I email
somebody within my co-op maybe I get
stronger promises than if the data needs
to leave the co-op and you could rethink
how you pay for services like this
another question you might ask is does
the service actually need to learn from
aggregate user data is the sort of the
current exchange one where basically
their goal is to learn trends
correlations things like this so things
where you see this sort for example
recommendation systems or navigation
software and then you could think about
well how can you redo this so that you
know ways doesn't actually need to know
where I am and there are people thinking
about actually questions along these
lines
so the learn the process of doing the
learning on on people's data could
actually potentially happen in the side
to the coop so the company could send
the coop their algorithm it could be
trained it on co-op data the coop could
then acts as a proxy for delivery of
information for delivery of goods for
delivery of payments recommendations
would get much better because they'd be
based on much more data potentially and
so they you know the new Amazon would
actually know exactly what you want to
buy and this you potentially though have
strict controls on the privacy risk from
the
or recommendations so their question
that's useful is I is it something is
this company doing something that really
probably can't immediately move inside
the coop for example because of
extraordinary computational requirements
a good example here is web search that's
probably not going to all happen inside
the coop so how can we control the
information that needs to leave the coop
in order to achieve the goals so you
might think about stripping queries of
an unnecessary identifying information
bundling them together somehow acting as
a proxy for payments so there's a lot of
thinking to be done about what are the
limits of what we can do depending on
what happens to happen where and what
does the service is being provided okay
as I mentioned before it could
potentially enable totally new
applications that you just can't you
can't do right now you could potentially
be you know nano targeting ads without
invading people's privacy because as we
talked about before company is
considered achieve all of their data
needs in one place I one interesting
thing that that coops help a lot with
potentially is secondary uses so what do
I mean by this in the current data
ecosystem it's really really basically
impossible to go back to somebody a
couple years later and say oh I want to
know one more thing about you you know
what you were in my survey three years
ago but I also need to know this and so
in order to make up for this difficulty
of getting back to people when you
collect data the thing to do is just
collect anything you could ever dream of
meeting in the future and get people to
agree to arbitrary uses of it because
then when you realize three years down
the line that I actually need this for
this other purpose you have it obviously
this is problematic from the perspective
of individual control and transparency
but data cops can potentially solve this
problem because you realize you need a
little bit more data from that specific
person you go back to the coop need a
little bit more information about this
particular population you go back to the
coop it's very obvious we
you go what the source is what the
procedure is and people already have
their agreements in place so it's a
matter of a click you don't have to go
and track them down and ask them
questions and have them sign new forms
data linkage we sometimes think of it as
an evil in the privacy world but it's
obviously you know huge opportunity and
we saw this analyst talk amazing things
you can potentially do if you can bring
together disparate sources there are
huge opportunities here and as I
mentioned before if you have sort of a
aneasha idea with a small target
audience much more feasible it's
imaginary world and the coop as I
mentioned is also taking on additional
roles that aren't currently served in
the data ecosystem consumer protection
role pretend potentially helping serve
some of the the purposes the the danny
alluded to earlier protecting political
discourse protecting our democracy
letting consumers have a way to vote
with their feet currently and there's
this sort of sense of data lock in with
a lot of applications you don't really
have a choice to pick up your data and
go somewhere else and that might be more
feasible in a co-op model and that might
provide more competition better choices
for people better protections higher
standards for the algorithms that you
get used on our data and the ability to
sort of have our voice be heard what are
our priorities for what should be
detected what should be guaranteed what
should be prioritized in terms of who
should have access to data and what
should be done with data
I want to hear what the purpose of the
coop idea is in the first place you know
I left four goals with you doing
innovation whether it be public interest
democracy or those things where are you
with our democracy you know all of us
have been saying in the current model
even like let people compete on the
basis of privacy and what I'm worried
about is that underneath the hood and
maybe you keep saying about individual
control but if you think that there's
some societal benefit which I'm not sure
how you can sweep up that many of us are
waiting to happen in the current level I
want to hear a little bit about what
value the cop is bringing that will
assure all of these things that's going
to be just as hard to secure nice give
us the size of any
right I it's a research agenda one piece
one piece of a possible answer is that
the the co-op's
creating a new political entity and
that's potentially a powerful entity
that I I don't know that there's a way
forward that doesn't involve regulatory
intervention at some point but maybe can
enact some of the things that you might
be hoping to do with regulatory
intervention may be able to do that in
another way but it's a research question
absolutely yeah the change potential
changing balance like actually if you
are trying to negotiate way about the
frame maybe bringing in you know
historian negotiation power can change
like the things that the people are
trying to do today are trying to get
into this thing of like changing that
and search that I think that this is a
pretty good question because when yes
today if I'm in legal trouble and I'm
rich I can hide yourself a really
expensive an excellent lawyer but if I'm
cool then I'm gonna wind up with you
know state-sponsored defense which is
not again it's not like to do it is to
say that certain thing it's for this
compact it to be anything different and
not just be able to rich people have
powerful cards that can get highest
prices for the data of those rich people
who've joined that expensive like Sports
Club or you know but you they need to
have some principles of that what is
this whole model trying to achieve in
society that is different from what we
have today and we'll achieve it but
without some of the when we look at
other agents in society what we did is
the rich pick the good ones etc and and
we have
the next slide
yes and absolutely there's a there's a
real concern of a future society with
data halves and data have-nots and I
think there's a whole space of really
big questions to talk about that yeah so
I thought I'd look to continue to talk
about this yeah maybe when you get to
failure modes there's also this issue
that you're creating a single major of
single point of a single point of
failure or a small yes that is the next
slide I don't have a solution to this
problem but is a huge problem and
basically the theme for the the you know
all continuing discussion is you should
think as much as you possibly can about
all the ways that this can go wrong and
all of us should dedicate a huge amount
of the effort in this space to think
about how this can go wrong and how we
can protect against those those risks
because I think this is I this is not
something to pursue lightly and so here
are a sample of a few of the things that
could possibly go wrong but it's just a
few of them and they're not fully
explored fat target for data fest fat
target for disruption harming
individuals risk of subpoena I the coop
could you know potentially act not
according to the interests of its
members or not according to the
agreements with its members I they're
interesting risks if the coop isn't
trusted by the data purchasers because
the data purchases are going to need to
entrust the coop in most scenarios with
fairly sensitive data about what they're
trying to achieve and they need to trust
the data that they get from the coop the
coop could be taken over could become
evil all sorts of things who go wrong in
this space and so a huge huge huge
research question is what are the tools
of various sorts technical tools legal
tools governance tools that you can put
in place in order to mitigate risks
I put in you know an emergency stop
button whatever it is what are the
things that you can put in place in
order to protect against all of these
concerns yeah the list is how do you
stop there being I mean all of these
dangers are more acute when you have a
very small number of these up style
entities however that seems to be what's
required to materialize the benefits of
actual you know if you want people with
clout and if you're arguing that the
whole idea is to give people collective
yeah yeah so there's a there's a very
interesting sort of tension about how to
structure the marketplace so that you
have the right amount of competition and
the right sort of benefits and yeah and
that's one of the questions that I think
yeah obviously there are a lot of
questions here and so I give a sample of
a few of the spaces of questions we have
started to collect these questions as
you'll see but I want to hear more from
all of you so I we have some sort of
ground rules that we put in place for
doing and work and thinking in this area
basically sort of openness transparency
kinds of themes really important but I
have only a couple of minutes so I'm
going to jump ahead emphasis on a
diversity of ideas diversity of model
diversity of tools and potentially
diversity of co-ops thinking about sort
of the benefits there so there are lots
of research areas that are relevant in
this space I'm gonna save all of the
markets and incentives questions for
tomorrow and I'll try to briefly talk
about some of the other ones so
questions like how much of the solution
needs to be legal and how much of it
needs to be technical and how does that
depend on the particular environment in
which you choose to launch this you know
if you launch this in the u.s. versus in
Israel versus in Europe what needs to be
changed with the mechanisms for change
can you identify
I I ways in which I current practices
with respect to data and infringe
individual rights it can you use that as
a tool sort of collecting an
understanding of the relevant I
intruments of Rights and the relevant
work that's been done in the legal space
I think it's already a major task in
this space and this is really just a
brief sampling I'll do it quickly in the
space of regulation and governance I
mean as some of this conversation is
already alluded to the the governance
structure of the coop is going to be
really important in helping it achieve
its goals as you have to think carefully
about how the coop gonna make it its
choices collectively what sort of legal
entity issue it should it be there's an
interesting I think going on here with
and the coop is potentially a big enough
entity that it's straddling in this odd
space where it's not really a
self-regulating thing it's potentially
doing something that resembles things
one might do with government regulation
but potentially not using government
regulation and as I mentioned before you
need to put in sort of technical and
legal safeguards to protect the data
users and the analysts from the coop as
well as protecting the the members of
the coop
so how do you do all of this what are
the right tools in this space yes
absolutely yeah that's a it's one of the
huge questions and then what are the
launch strategies and I think this is
this is a really fun one to think about
you know do you focus on a particular
type of data in terms of you know do you
focus on medical data first do you focus
on data that's currently not being
collected and start collecting a new you
know rich data set that's not available
to anybody do you think that this should
launch in a particular country with a
particular demographic with a particular
you where how how many people do you
need in order and for this thing to
actually be providing value on both
sides
how do you get to that point what are
the things that are gonna stop you along
the way so huge number of questions to
know should have called the merge from
existing organizations pros and cons of
it coming out of a hospital out of a
government out of a you name it and then
you know risk risk risk and concerns
concerns concerns and then a big part of
this is starting a conversation across
the many disciplines that are relevant
in the space so how do we come together
to understand each other to build
something that involves tools from many
different disciplines and solves a
problem that we all care about and lots
of technical questions privacy questions
security questions
HCI questions I mean huge questions how
do you get people to be able to express
their preferences and understand what's
going on with their data we really don't
know how to do this but lots of
interesting questions formal
verification be potentially a huge
player in this space and then I said I
would save it all for for tomorrow and I
basically well but there are lots of
interesting economic questions and
scented questions mechanism design
questions in this space and some of the
ones that we won't really get to
tomorrow so I'll just mention them now
how do you said and control the
incentives of the organization as a
whole how should you think about
managing privacy budgets for individuals
and across time how should you think
about mission creep and how to control
against us how can we potentially use
the tech the coop to detect and project
against data being used to manipulate
people and they said well that's more
coming in this space tomorrow so I just
wanted to say again this is about
bringing people together to figure out
what the questions should be this is not
a proposal to do something specific or
build something specific we don't have
answers we have some questions we want
more questions and then maybe some
answers so join us I will be chatting
probably briefly after the the group
meeting tomorrow just to sort of have an
initial organizational meeting for a few
minutes but if you can't make that in
your interest in coop so you can get
into
with me or Kobe we'll be having a weekly
meeting where we plan to do a
combination of a reading group bringing
papers from all of these related areas
together and not just papers but sort of
other readings and and then we plan to
think of this as sort of a working group
we'd like hopefully for people to start
peeling off pieces of this space that
are interesting to them and working out
you know what are the questions that
should be asked what are the tensions
what are the related literature's
potentially producing over the course of
the semester some research agendas white
papers starting to identify what what we
can do in this space and I think an
important thing to keep in mind is even
if you I don't think we've got it
you know just write with what I've said
here there should be a question for you
somewhere in the space given you're in
this room and so I'd love to hear more
about the the connections concerns
critiques ideas that you have
[Applause]